(individual keyboard notes played calmly)
- I'm in MoMA's storage
with Ernst Ludwig Kirchner's
The Street Berlin painted in 1913.
Kirchner had moved to Berlin
a couple of years earlier
with other members of the
expressionist painter group,
Die Brücke, but by 1913
many of them had left
and he was there in the city on his own.
This is one of a number of
street scenes he painted
all characterized as this
work is by this vivid
anti-naturalistic color.
These spilling perspectives
and this very very visible brush stroke.
All hallmarks of expressionist painting.
You instantly recognize
that Kirchner's subject
is not the city per se,
instead his true subject
is the psychological
experience of an individual
in this very large,
overcrowded urban metropolis.
At this point, Berlin was
the third largest city
in the world, and Kirchner
clearly is responding to that
in the way that he
structures this composition.
The figures in the very
center are two prostitutes
who for him embodied not
only glamour and alienation,
but the sad reality of a
culture in which everything
was for sale.
You see them surrounded by this relatively
faceless anonymous mask
right of these black garbed
suited men.
None of whom engage them directly.
These are symbolic
representations of a form
of urban angst that is
made all the more dramatic
by the way that he tilts
and spills this composition
out toward us.
The effect is claustrophobic, I think,
for us as a viewer and is reminiscent
of what it must have
been like for Kirchner
to experience the streets
of Berlin in 1913.
(individual keyboard notes played calmly)